Spotify has stopped even sort of trying
to stem Joe Rogan's vaccine
misinformation he's also claiming that
Rogan is spreading misinformation on
Spotify but he had no problem going on
Rogan's show to say whatever it is that
he wanted he said Peter if you claim
what RFK Jr is saying is misinformation
I am offering you a hundred thousand
dollars to the charity of your choice if
you're willing to debate him on my show
with no time limit Elon then responded
to Joe and said he's afraid of public
debate because he knows he's wrong then
this guy Tom Nichols who's a staffer at
the Atlantic I think he's occasionally
on MSNBC he responded with this and you
can now start to see how the lines were
being drawn on what side people are on
uh he said no medical professional
should ever agree to do this this is
what they've done with everybody right
they label you a conspiracy theorist or
you're a racist or a bigot or a
homophobic transformed so that they
don't have to debate you right that's
basically how everything has operated